die einen kommen die anderen gehen er
geht heute andreas Scheuer
Verkehrsminister letzte Kabinettssitzung
beginnt in 14 Minuten im Kanzleramt so
lange hat er netterweise Zeit für Bild
live schönen guten Tag Herr scheuer
hallo guten Tag sind sie wehmütig heute
wenn es heißt Abschied zu nehmen letzte
Kabinettssitzung
also ich habe mich auf Abschied noch
nicht eingestellt die Bundesregierung
arbeitet weiter als geschäftsführende
Bundesregierung auch nach diese
Kabinettssitzung natürlich leben wir es
dabei klar und man wollte seine Arbeit
fortsetzen habe große Freude daran
gehabt dem Land als Bundesminister zu
dienen aber Demokratie ist auch immer
Zeitvertrag und der Welle hat anders
entschieden oder die Konstellation ist
anders geworden und klar natürlich ist
wemo bei der letzten Kabinettssitzung
aber die Arbeit geht weiter und bis eine
Regierung eingesetzt ist und der
Bundespräsident die Einsetzung gemacht
hat geht die Arbeit weiter wir haben ja
die Signale das am 8.12 der Kanzler
gewählt wird und dann die Regierung
steht bis dahin hatte die Ampel auch
noch einiges zu tun nämlich die
Gremiensitzungen die diesen
Koalitionsvertrag gehen wir auch nicht
kennen erst an der annehmen müssen also
von daher da hat man schon viel erlebt
trotzdem stelle ich mich natürlich auf
Abschied ein
aber die Lage die wir in Deutschland
haben ist auch bei dieser letzten
Kabinettssitzung was die cordona
Pandemie betrifft äußerst
besorgniserregend und diese
geschäftsführende Bundesregierung hat
noch einiges zu tun weil die
Ampelkoalition Ehre sich der Lage
scheinbar nicht bewusst sind
also ich muss Jan Schäfer ein bisschen
korrigieren die Entlassungsurkunde haben
wir ja schon bekommen aber
gleichzeitig in die Einsetzung durch den
Bundespräsidenten dass wir
Geschäftsführern im Amt sind das
Abendessen als auch schon gegeben bei
der Kanzlerin also jetzt wird die
Tagesordnung abgearbeitet dann wird im
Anschluss noch ein Foto gemacht von der
scheidenden Bundesregierung aber
trotzdem noch mal Deutschland hat
weiterhin eine geschäftsführende
Bundesregierung und solange kein Kanzler
gewählt ist und eine neue
Bundesregierung eingesetzt ist muss man
arbeiten werde ich arbeiten weil die
Lage ist wirklich höchst angespannt
und die Zahlen der Corona Pandemie
zeigen dass wir unglaublich viel noch
diskutieren müssen die Kanzlerin hat
gestern die
Ampel Koalitionäre eingeladen um die
Dramatik der Lage noch mal ihnen näher
zu bringen denn diese Maßnahmen die die
Ampel jetzt letzte Woche
beschlossen hat die reichen nicht um
diese Bälle zu brechen die eine Seite
ist ja die allgemeine Impfpflicht wofür
ich bin die bricht aber noch nicht jetzt
gerade in diesen Tagen die Welle wenn
wir in einer Woche eine erhebliche
Steigerung der Fallzahlen sehen dann
glaube ich es auch eine
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die jetzt
am 9.12 angesetzt ist zu spät und da
müssen wir jetzt handeln und wir sind
jetzt gerade dabei
Herrn Scholz Lindner und dann Harbeck
davon zu überzeugen dass es mehr an
Maßnahmen braucht und die die jetzt
beschlossen sind die Reichen im Net das
verstehen wir und wie gesagt wir werden
uns gleich darum kümmern gestern gab's
ja genau diese Krisensitzung sozusagen
das einberufen der Ampel Koalitionäre
der künftigen ins Kanzleramt treffen da
von 17 Uhr bis etwa 18 Uhr dreißig Uhr
wir waren ja sozusagen mit unseren
Kameras dabei Herr scheuer trotzdem noch
einmal den Gedanken zu lassen das ist
was Besonderes jetzt Abschied zu nehmen
was machen sie in den nächsten Tagen mit
den Kartons im eigenen Büro Dienstwagen
z.b. abgeben wissen Sie schon wie das
konkret läuft also wie gibt der
Verkehrsminister sein Dienstwagen ab
ja ich bin in meinem Wahlkreis Pastor
gewählt als ob gewonnen oder ich werde
oppositions Abgeordneter sein und die
Regierung kontrollieren ich habe schon
einen Teil eingepackt und aufgeräumt
also ich bin
Logistik Minister gut gerüstet einen
Teil gibt es noch den ich noch einpacken
muss dann werden wir es Demokraten share
den Nachfolgern das Haus übergeben ich
werde wenn ich weiß wer es ist und es
ist glaube ich Anton Hofreiter ihn
bitten dass wir ein intensives vier
Augen Gespräch machen damit er auch ein
paar Themen von mir mitnehmen kann dies
biete ich an und dann werde ich mich an
meine Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
des sind in den Ministerien in Bonn und
Berlin rund 1500 Beschäftigte und in der
nachgelagerten Behörden ich habe 60
nachgelagerte Behörden in meiner
Verantwortung gehabt sind es insgesamt
40 000 Beschäftigte da werde ich mich ja
bedanken
werde auch dokumentieren dass sie gut
gearbeitet haben für Deutschland ich
habe die Politik Verantwortung in den
letzten Jahren gehabt und über
Dienstwagen mache ich mich jetzt keine
Sorge ich bin überzeugter
mobilitäts Politiker ich werde meinen
Dienstwagen abgeben und dann wieder ganz
normal unterwegs sein
das hoffe ich macht der auch und
manchmal bin ich auch mit dem Rad
gefahren ich werde mir das als
Oppositionspolitiker anschauen ob ihr
reden im Deutschen Bundestag als
Oppositionsführer Anton Hofreiter zu dem
passt was er dann als Minister macht
ja das ist der absolute Wahnsinn ich
kann nicht eingreifen den die neue
Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag aus SPD
Grüne und liberalen haben das mit einem
Gesetz des sie vorgelegt haben
beschlossen wir haben letzte Woche
unsere fachliche Expertise eingebracht
mit wissenschaftlicher Begleitung seit
früher 20/20 ist der öffentliche Verkehr
die öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln ein
niedriges Infektionsrisiko laut
Robert-Koch-Institut wir haben davor
gewarnt bei der praktischen Umsetzung
dann hat die Ampel auch noch aus meiner
Sicht einen Riesenfehler gemacht
umgesetzt nämlich diese Bußgelder die
Sie ansprechen wirklich 2500 € bis auf
25000 € hochgehen das steht so schwarz
auf weiß im Gesetz dass die Ampel gegen
die Union beschlossen hat
und jetzt werden die Länder des heilen
müssen also die Ampel Männern
stolz Lindner und Habeck sind
verantwortlich auch für dieses disaster
und jetzt ist auch klar dass wir eine
Ampelkoalition haben die sich der
Dramatik der Lage auf der einen Seite
nicht bewusst ist was die wirklich
wirksamen Maßnahmen betrifft und auf der
anderen Seite Maßnahmen einführt die in
der praktischen Umsetzung zu erheblichen
Problemen führen also das heißt wir
haben fachlich in einer Stellungnahme
die Ampelkoalition beraten aber es ging
schon längst nicht mehr letzte Woche um
das ob der Einführung ist er 3G Regel in
den öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln sondern
nur noch umsetzen eine basta Politik
schon noch ein paar Wochen
Herr Minister mit der Bitte um eine
kurze Antwort weil sie auch gleich in
den Kabinettssaal dann müssen aber wenn
sie auf der einen Seite sagen die Ampel
verschärft die Maßnahme nicht stark
genug also es geht Euch zu lasch mit
Corona um und zum anderen geht es um
Kontakt reduzierungen und die Frage wie
verhalte ich mich da auch im
öffentlichen Raum wieso dann ihre
masivet Kritiken an dem was jetzt
geplant ist und auch an diesen hohen
Bußgeldern die sind doch dann einig
gerechtfertigt oder nicht
weil wir ja seit früher 20/20 alle
Verkehrsmittel des öffentlichen Verkehrs
genau analysiert haben vom Zug über Bus
bis hin zum Flugzeug wir haben
wissenschaftliche Begleitung uns geholt
wir haben andere Hygienekonzepte
desinfektions Zyklen
Reinigungskonzepte allem mit dieser
Begleitung der Wissenschaftler ob
Drosten oder DLR haben festgestellt dass
die öffentlichen Verkehrsmittel geben
kein hohes Infektionsrisiko
sondern ein niedriges
wo haben weil sich dann die
Luftzirkulation
bemerkbar macht positiv weil die
Menschen natürlich auch die Maske tragen
und die Massen Pflicht schon längst
beschlossen ist also gute Gründe
fachliche Gründe dass man diese 3G
Regelungen öffentlichen Verkehrsmittel
im nicht anwendet aber trotzdem klar ist
dass die Maßnahmen die beschlossen
wurden letzte Woche von der Ampel jetzt
wenn ich mir den Pandemie Verlauf
anschaue einfach nicht reichen um diese
Welle zu brechen der Song auf alle
Experten wenn wir nächste Woche eine
Verdoppelung der Fallzahlen haben dann
ist es eine traurige Entwicklung weil
die Ampel einfach an dieser Stelle den
falschen Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt hat sie
hat sich auf Stück mehr konzentriert auf
einzelne Dinge die man ins Schaufenster
stellt aber nicht auf das Wesentliche
nämlich auf auch die Frage wie wir mit
dem Impfen noch besser werden das ist
die zweite Säule die hier mittelfristig
ist mit mir nicht im Februar als die
nächste Welle haben brauchen wir jetzt
auch eine seriöse offene Diskussion über
die allgemeine Impfpflicht wenn die Lage
so ist und ich bin für absolute Freiheit
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger aber wenn wir
es so mit diesem Mittel nicht
hinbekommen dann müssen wir an dieser
Stelle auch über die Impfpflicht reden
Herr scheuer sie müssen gleich
Internetseite deswegen letzte Fragen es
gibt verletzte Dienstreise die sie
machen am 1. Dezember wenn wir richtig
informiert sind nach LA was bringt das
noch wenn sie wenige Tage später gar
nicht am Minister sind ist das eine
sinnvolle Reise oder ist das mehr eine
Lustreise
ja ich mache nur sinnvolle Reisen weil
wir haben die Dramatik dass wir in der
allgemeinen Logistik global gesehen
einen wirklichen Stillstand haben von
Rohstoffversorgung und viel mehr ich
werde da vor allem die Hafenlogistik mir
anschauen mit Betreibern reden wir sind
logistikweltmeister wir sind
Exportweltmeister wir müssen uns darum
kümmern dass aus China und nach China
die Exporte funktionieren und auch die
Vereinigten Staaten haben wirklich
Notlage angemeldet das was wir seit
Wochen diskutieren ist ein bisschen
untergegangen in der allgemeinen Corona
Pandemie Diskussion deswegen muss man
sich jetzt drum kümmern damit die
Logistikwirtschaft und damit auch die
die Industrie hier in Deutschland gut
versorgt bleibt deswegen mache ich diese
Tage in USA auch kombiniert mit einer
Automesse die vor allem sehr viel an
Schwerpunkt Mobilität der Zukunft hat
dann möchte ich meinem Nachfolger ein
gut bestelltes Haus mit guten m
Formationen hinterlassen alles geklärt
vielen Dank Andreas scheue müssen ich
gleich eigentlich ihren Impfpass
vorzeigen wenn sie ins Kanzleramt gehen
das muss ja ganz Deutschland heute am
Eingang zur Arbeit
ich schätze mal dass das Land sich auch
auf die neuen Regeln eingerichtet hat
danke andreas Scheuer der noch
Verkehrsminister kurz vor der letzten
Kabinettssitzung heute mit Angela Merkel
im Kabinettssaal das Kanzleramt danke
für das Gespräch